well you know i mean the film industry
has had as a whole has had this
remarkable impact on American culture
and psyche it's spawned almost
everything that we think about America
and you know so that just you look
technologically that has been profound
from advances in all the technologies
that until today we have video on demand
and all the ability for average people
to watch our product this is the one
thing this is the great democratizing
industry you don't have to be rich to
enjoy what we do you go into a theater
and you're going to pay nine dollars or
ten dollars you're going to sit there
with three or four hundred people
diverse backgrounds and people you
wouldn't otherwise be friends with
necessarily and but for that two-hour
period of time you're you're
collectively watching one thing and I
think that's something you don't find in
virtually any other business maybe
sports a little bit but not certainly
the same concentrated fashion you do in
this business